Jean Edward Smith author of Bush when
did you first think that it was worth
doing a biography so close to his
presidency I had just finished the
Eisenhower biography I was in New York
having lunch with my editor at Random
House at the time and he said what do
you want to do next
this is just F Eisenhower in 2012 and I
said how about George Bush and he said
fine and so we started on George Bush
why I thought he needed to be treated I
thought I didn't think any of the books
that were out at that time this was been
2012 adequately treated him
let me read I just I'm gonna jump into
chapter 12 and read the first paragraph
george w bush was regarded by many of
his classmates at Harvard Business
School as dynamically ignorant he was
energetic but ill-formed
informed ill-informed untutored and
unread and he fought 'added little had
changed in his 2002 State of the Union
and the the phrase axis of evil wreaked
of arrogance and obtuseness once again
Bush has spoken without weighing the
consequences I think I think that's
right
and I think that's why someone hadn't
had to write and say that when did you
start to feel this way about him oh when
it was present why well because it
seemed to me that there was absolutely
no reason to go into to Iraq and and and
his domestic policies Orient's his
response let's put it this way his
response to 9/11 seemed to me totally
overdrawn where were you in 9/11 what
had happened hmm
we were in Huntington West Virginia do
you remember the day I know I remember
my wife [ __ ] singing on television and I
can't it was a sunny day and I can't
remember I was on the faculty at
Marshall at the time and I was I was
down to university when did you begin to
react negatively to the way he handled
9/11 oh I think when the I would say
beginning with the the treatment of
prisoners Guantanamo which seemed which
seemed totally out of the ordinary and
of course the domestic spying that that
took place but of course those weren't
really very well known until the
articles came out in the New York Times
in the Washington Post about two years
later here's george w bush when he was
not in office in 1991 an interview that
was done in texas unfortunately there's
a bunch of these kind of I would call
them minor leaguers who view themselves
as major-league writers who who attacked
George Bush in a personal way you
wouldn't be talking about George will
would ya there's one nicer one and those
kind of things hurt it not anymore
I don't even read the guy anymore so I
can't tell you if he's been personal or
not but when he read your father being
called a lap dog by by a person of his
stature I'm not sure I mean large
stature or small stature it bothers you
particularly if you're a feisty Texan
which I am what's your reaction when you
see them about that's that's George Bush
in 1991 and he ran for governor in 1994
he was he was head of the Texas Rangers
of that at that time and that's George
Bush what do you see there spontaneity
and really a lack of sustained judgment
a lack of intellectual insight
have you ever met him no dictate you
whom I interviewed a number of times for
the book set up an interview for me with
George Bush found in Dallas and just
before I was to go out I got a telephone
call from one of his aides who said the
president doesn't want to see you has
decided not to see you because you wrote
a book critical of his father which is
true in 1992 I published a book called
George Bush's a war which was critical
of George Herbert Walker Bush his
decision to attack Iraq at the time the
the curious thing in some ways is that
in 1997 the University of Toronto
decided to give George Herbert Walker
Bush an honorary degree and Rob
Pritchard the university president said
gene you're going to introduce him
because you wrote a book about him
and I said what the book is critical and
he said doesn't matter so I introduced
George Bush at the ceremony and we had
about 1,500 demonstrators outside
protesting this was a difficult award
the U of T was giving him an award for
ending the Cold War but but the
demonstrators outside 1,500 to 2,000
1000 to 1500 we're protesting as being
head of the CIA which in Canada is not a
popular thing to be are you a Canadian
citizen I'm both I'm in America I was
born in the United States I'm an
American citizen but I went to Toronto
in the 1960s and in the 1970s the
Supreme Court in a decision at friend
versus Rusk made it possible to hold
dual citizenship and so at that point I
became the Canadian citizen as well
Warren you vote in Mississippi why
because that's where my parents are from
that's where the family is from and we
owned property in Mississippi and I've
always voted in Mississippi go back to
your book on George Herbert Walker Bush
why were you critical of his activities
back in the first Iraq war but bear in
mind that when when Bush went to
Congress and asked for permission to
attack Iraq
after the vid Saddam and moved into
Kuwait this was a very close vote Bush
only won by about ten ten votes in the
House of Representatives and maybe even
less than the Senate all night so this
was not this was not a popular thing at
the time the comment by George W Bush
about George will George Will has called
you one of the finest weot biographers
we have as a country I don't think
George is gonna like this book but why
not well I think George is a Republican
he just dropped out everybody well I I
saw that I saw that I don't know I don't
know maybe you will well how would you
describe your own politics Democrat I'm
from I'm from Mississippi at a time when
people in Mississippi voted Democratic
how would you define your ideology or
where you are on the spectrum Oh
on the left on the left always been
there yes I think I went to Princeton as
an undergraduate in 52:54 Paul sarbanes
is a classmate of mine Don Rumsfeld is
too but I I think most of us then were
Democratic Adlai Stevenson ran for
president you may recall in 1952 and and
also in 1956 and he's a Princeton
graduate yes the best I could find it
read in the back where you say where you
got your material on the notes is that
you had a three or four or five
interviews two of them that seemed to be
the most important were Don Rumsfeld and
Dick Cheney is given what you said about
George Herbert Walker Bush and all that
why would Dick Cheney's see you how did
you work that out Rumsfeld set it up for
me and why did would start with that Don
ROM so why did he see in our classmates
we've note we've known each other since
1950 we lived in the same dorm entry
freshman year so we we've known each
other for for since 1950 at what school
and we live in the same dorm entry and
don is a very popular member of the
class of 1954 how often did you talk to
him for the book hmm maybe 20 times and
what did you learn from him that you
didn't know from I mean I've seen a lot
of the sources in your book are other
books that have been written about
George Bush yes
iiiiii I felt that he was always very
frank and and very honest I mean we've
known each other for a very long time
and so there was no problem interviewing
interviewing Don and I know his wife and
you know he knows my wife friendly what
what do you think his role was in the
whole Iraq war and did you tell him what
you thought about it oh yes oh yes and I
believe that he thought and the military
thought that they were going in as
liberators they were going to get rid of
Saddam Hussein find any weapons of mass
destruction if they were there and leave
within 90 days and that's what they
planned for that they didn't plan just
to occupy Iraq that Frank's Colonel
Frank's plan for that on Rumsfeld
instructions the military and the State
Department believed they were going in
to remove Saddam Hussein find the
weapons of mass destruction and get out
very quickly and Jay garner the the
general in charge of of that of dealing
with the Iraqis had a council ready to
take charge and then on May 1st when
Bush spoke on the flight deck of the
Abraham Lincoln you recall with the
banner it said mission accomplished Bush
Bush changed changed change the ground
rules which said we're going to stay
we're going to occupy Iraq and and and
bring in democracy they hadn't planned
for that they hadn't planned for that at
all that they were taken totally by
surprise when Bush
on May 1st on the flight deck of the
Abraham Lincoln said we're going to
bring democracy to Iraq now the
difference between liberators which they
thought they were going to be and being
occupiers is profound liberators make a
country free occupiers impose their will
and the military had a plan for that the
military plan to go in get out and so
suddenly they're caught being occupiers
and it simply we're not prepared for it
here's George Bush at West Point speech
that you write about June 1st 2002 -
before the war started in March of 2007
summit address at West Point for much of
the last century America's defense
relied on the Cold War doctrines of
deterrence and containment in some cases
those strategies still apply but new
threats also require new thinking the
war on terror will not be won on the
defensive we must take the battle to the
enemy disrupt his plans and confront the
worst threats before they emerge
preemption and and and Bush Bush did
announce that at West Point and on his
own the military were not prepared for
that and and it's he was absolutely
wrong and I don't know what else you
could say at one point in your book you
bring up gog and magog yes why and who
were they or what is it
maybe Bush's worst fault is the fact
that he is a born-again Christian who
brings that ideology into into the
presidency he believes that he was God's
agent here on earth to fight evil and
you mentioned Gog and Magog just before
the Iraqi invasion Bush called president
chirac of France on the telephone trying
to get France to join Drennen in the
attack
and during the course of that
conversation he told Chirac that we're
fighting Gog and Magog before the final
judgement now Gog and Magog or creatures
in the book of Revelation of the New
Testament that's that that's the the the
center of the universe for many
evangelicals and and fundamentalist
Christians and and Bush generally
believe that people generally genuinely
believed that he was God's agent here on
earth to fight evil if you believe that
whether it's in the domestic excesses or
the war against Iraq if you believe you
are God's agent fighting evil all holes
are removed you're a blank slate and and
you can do whatever is necessary to
fight evil I might say that Chirac
didn't know what he was talking about
and he finally his staff didn't know
either and they finally got a professor
at the University of in Basel to cool
him in talk to what it was and that of
course convinced Rockwell the more that
he didn't want any part of this you got
that from Kirk Kirk I can walls this
book kind of 500 days secrets and lies
and tear Wars I'm tried and he used a
lot of his quotes from Facebook I don't
know a lot but some yeah well I know
it's noticeable but there are a lot of
others you did - yeah but how do you
decide as a historian what to quote what
to trust and what book to trust
Oh III III III don't know I don't I mean
it seems to me that as I read it if it
seems reasonable and logical I use it
and in it but there's no litmus test in
preparation for writing this particular
biography how much reading did you do
before you started writing it's that's
an interesting question
the writers write in different ways
I research each chapter as I go I do not
research the entire book before I begin
some writers do but but I research a
chapter by chapter and go from there
when I'm right now I'm writing a book
I do it every seven days a week I get up
at 5:30 in the morning and I work until
around noon but I do that seven days a
week but but I do it chapter by chapter
Caro
on the other hand researches for two or
three years before he starts to write
it's yeah I'd say he and our extremes on
one side and on the other it's just I've
always found do it that way what ask
either you've written a lot of
biographies and I want to go down the
list and ask you to compare what you
found out about these people and compare
it with george w bush we'll start with
the the the presidents in 2001 year
wrote grant Ulysses Grant that's right
and one of the ways that you're defined
in one of the reviews I read in on
Amazon is it greatly underrated
president is that the way you felt about
it that is yes that's very true and and
I think Grant was was not going to read
it at the time when Grant died a man and
a half people went to his funeral
the parade of Broadway in New York Grant
was very popular at the time but but
Grant as president genuinely believed in
racial equality and he kept the United
States Army in the South throughout his
presidency to maintain equal rights for
African Americans for the next three
generations that was not popular in
South and southern historians for the
next three generations trash grant
because of his sand because of his
determination to enforce racial equality
and so grants reputation suffered
enormous Lee and improperly at the same
it seemed to me and so I spent the time
to trying to rehabilitate him
is there any come
you can make between us grant and George
W Bush you mean I I don't think there's
any similarity grant was always very
reflective grant spent his time at West
Point most of it in the library reading
books and and then as you as you know
he's his own autobiography his since the
standard pretty much for for
presidential biographies autobiographies
no I think you could say that that the
distinction is probably light-years
apart
I mean polar opposites grant was did not
act on impulse
never your book was seven hundred eighty
four pages long this is a big book all
of your books have been pretty big
what's your approach to this and why in
this day and age when people are
supposedly not reading as much to the
publisher one a big book I you left that
as a publisher but but it seems to me if
you're writing a biographer you you have
to you have to write a big book and and
and that's I think that's why I say I
don't research the entire book before I
begin I do a chapter by chapter because
because if you're if you're writing a
book that's 700 or 800 pages you can't
remember all of that the next one is
your book on FDR in 2007 just I was 880
pages one of the reviewers said changed
the relationship between the American
people and their government yes he did
in the sense that beginning with the
beginning with the New Deal Roosevelt
caused people to look to Washington for
support which they hadn't done
previously and the government became a
big supporter of the economy and of
people and I think I think in that sense
Roosevelt did indeed change change the
approach you call in your book you say
that George Bush was the decider just
like he used to say what do you think of
that and was FDR a decider
and is there any comparison between
those two
FDR occasionally well let me when he did
that he usually made a mistake the
Supreme Court plan in 1937 to expand the
size of the Supreme Court was done on
his own he consulted no one on that and
the his attempt to increase the size of
the court from nine to fifteen justices
caught everyone by surprise and it was
it was a terrible mistake
so when President acted that way it was
a terrible mistake I will say that the
only other example I can think of in
roseville acted on his own was when he
overruled general Marshall and secretary
Stimson 1942 and ordered the invasion of
North Africa they didn't want to do that
and he ordered the invasion of North
Africa those those are the two principle
examples I can think of with Grant and
FDR and the next eisenhower worded
religion play out with them compared to
george w bush most people don't realize
it but Dwight Eisenhower is the only
president who was elected who did not
belong to a church Eisenhower was a
cadet at West Point graduate in the
class of 15 West Point cadets at that
time were required to go to Chapel every
Sunday and so when Eisenhower graduated
he decided he wasn't going back
MacArthur once asked him in the 1930s
when he was when the court said was
chief of staff in Eisenhower was his
assistant
why didn't go to church and Eisenhower
said because because I had to go every
Sunday at West Point I'm not going back
and he didn't go back
he finally joined the Presbyterian
Church but not until after he was
elected president so I I think I think
that that's a fundamental distinction
grant was was not a belief it was not a
true believer either
Roosevelt I was was always was a an
elder in his church at Hyde Park but I
think also he was quite skeptical and
your book on George Herbert Walker Bush
where do you think religion played a
part with him I don't think it did the
book on George Herbert Walker Bush was
just about the Iraq war so it's a narrow
book and it's a couple of pages I don't
think it did
I mean it's George W Bush Bush 43 is a
born-again Christian he he got to that
position in the 1980s and you talk about
Billy Graham in here and his
relationship to George W Bush but you
also give credit to another minister yes
I think it was the other minister the
the person who he carried the cross
around the world so-called a year before
who really brought Bush back or who made
Bush a born-again Christian mission and
both of his autobiographies George W
Bush credits Billy Graham but I think
that's because Billy Graham is known and
the other fellow is not in 2011 George
Bush talked about sustaining being
sustained by his faith and it let's just
watch a little bit of this and continue
I was sustained by my faith during my
presidency and I did pray a lot and I
saw God's wonders in many occasion when
I was president I tell the story about
the rainbow in Bucharest Romania I gave
a speech and right before I got on the
stage somebody pointed out this balcony
that was lit it was the place where the
tyrant had given his last speech and
amidst this rainstorm a rainbow appears
in and ended right behind the balcony
and I people can describe anything they
want to it I ascribed it as a as a
message that said freedom is beautiful
and universal and everybody desires to
live live
free life what do you think what are you
thinking as you listen to that I thought
that's exactly right I thought that that
wish received his his marching
instructions he thought from God what if
he's right
I don't think it was do you well my
question though is how do we know the
excesses domestically and the attack on
Iraq I don't think you could I don't
think it can be argued that they were
correct I want to complete the
comparisons with Eisenhower that was a
976 page book that was in 2012 just four
years ago and one of them you said a
canny politician and a skillful decisive
leader how do you compare what
Eisenhower was compared to what george w
bush's i can only think of eisenhower as
president making two mistakes and one of
them was when he gave the CIA permission
to topple - oliver puts a topple
Mosaddegh and and iran and the other was
when he authorized the YouTube flight
just before the Paris summit in 1960
otherwise Eisenhower one of Eisenhower's
great strengths was his ability to
conceal his hand Eisenhower was behind
the move that that ultimately - defeated
- Joe McCarthy III Eisenhower it was
Eisenhower who picked Joseph Welch to be
the council there than those Senate
hearings and Eisenhower like to conceal
what he was doing but but I think he was
incredibly efficient the interstate
highway system the st. Lawrence Seaway
ending the war in Korea I sent hard men
elected on a platform you thought that
he was going to go over and win the war
in Korea he went over and looked at it
and so it couldn't be won and so we
immediately made peace I think and I
think as I mentioned is there two
mistakes I think Eisenhower made but but
I think I've never had an incredibly
effective track record okay we've got
grant and FDR and Eisenhower and he also
did a book on John Marshall of all the
books you've done so far which of these
individuals did you personally like the
most I liked grant most why because I
thought that grant had been totally
underrated and had had been
systematically abused by southern
historians for three generations who
resented grant's position on racial
equality and I might say that when I was
a little boy of seven eight or nine
years old my father went from
Mississippi as as I said earlier took us
to the battlefield in Shiloh and my
cousins who were there with us were
saying well the South could have won if
they'd done this or done that and my
father said that we should rush up
because it's a good thing that grant was
in command that day and because grants
had saved the Union so I think from the
time I was eight years old I was on
grant side the reviews that have come
out on yours I'm pretty positive Peter
Baker and you used Peter Baker's book I
do in yours
he says and as July 4th review as a
biographer mr. Smith makes no
comparisons with today's Republican
leader but he cites unmistakeably with
those who see mr. Bush's presidency in
the darkest shades if often for
radically different reasons mr. Smith
abhors waterboarding terror suspects
what about in terror suspect for example
mr. Trump once it resumed what did you
think of his analysis of your book well
I was I was I was certainly very
flattered that Peter Baker wrote that
such a favorable review
because Baker's days a fire is a major
major work on the on the bush
administration it's not a biography of
zits it's a book on the administration
and but it's extremely good the headline
on that review is presidential biography
as scathing indictment it's fair yes yes
that's fair and and I think which
deserves a scathing indictment it do you
feels just as strong about george w
bush's you have any of the presents that
you've known you've written about you
thought about it's difficult for but for
a biographer to write about someone whom
you don't like and and i mean all these
other people eisenhower grant roosevelt
marshall were successful people who
deserved I thought a breeze and and it's
it's much more difficult to write about
someone whom you think is wrong well
another review into why shouldn't post
David Greenberg writes about East from
Rutgers written and sober smooth snarky
snark free prose with an air of
thoughtful detached Authority the book
is nonetheless exceedingly damning and
its judgments about george w bush's
years of office it reminds us anew of
George Bush's own arrogance recklessness
strong-arm politics and scorn for ideas
and of the apoplexy he provoked from
liberals and Democrats who felt
powerless to rein him in why do you
think he was elected twice I think the
Democrats blew both elections I think Al
Gore who ran against him in 2000 from
the beginning screwed it up political
science association meeting here in
Washington in the summer of 2000 all of
the political scientists who
analyzed elections and so forth
unanimously big big quarter win but but
but but he began by he began by picking
joseph Lieberman as his running mate
Lieberman who was the most conservative
Democrat in Congress in the Senate and
then he was he was he snubbed Bill
Clinton throughout the campaign I mean
he didn't invite Clinton to be on the
platform with him at the Democratic
convention when he was nominated he
I think his treatment of Clinton and
also both of those two factors paved the
way for Ralph Nader to come in and pick
up almost three million votes oh and
when the votes were counted Gore failed
to carry ten states that Clinton carried
in the 1996 election well when you
failed to carry 10 states including his
own state of Tennessee including
Arkansas including West Virginia no no
Republican had carried West Virginia
since Herbert Hoover ran against Al
Smith in 1928 but why it was George W
Bush re-elected and 2004 after after the
war fair enough
Kerry didn't ran a run run a good
campaign either recalled Kerry's
saluting at the Democratic convention
and the Democrats ran a traditional
campaign in in 2004 I think they were
appealing to the voter in the middle and
which they were fewer and carry was
carried in very well in the debates
against Bush but
IIIi think that that he just didn't run
as effective campaign he didn't he
wasn't as critical of Bush as he could
have been I think if he'd been much more
critical of Bush I think he would have
done much better let's go back to your
research on this book you interviewed
Richard Armitage does it
you interviewed David Fromm hmm you had
a interesting meal with General Petraeus
at the cosmos club that's already made
news and Politico came up with a story
from what is that I do a footnote let me
ask you just about that how did that was
it a lunch or a dinner what's the dinner
how did that come about
I was here in Washington at the time and
I got an email one day from General
Petraeus inviting me for dinner - dinner
at the cosmos club
I'd never General Petraeus before and
it's always just just as I was leaving
that evening my wife said now don't talk
about I can Kay Summersby and and so
after the first course was over that's
what he wanted to talk about so we
didn't that was the reason that he had
asked you to dinner I would think so
since he didn't he did he didn't know me
when was that when did this dinner come
about hmm maybe well it came about just
after he was forced out instead of the
CIA he came just after he resigned as
president as I said of the CIA because
of the polar Broadwell affair so he was
he was he was interesting I guess he was
interested now I could handle ok
Sommersby which it's which it's fair
enough I think
I mean III wasn't particularly surprised
by it because I can't let very well and
I think one of the reasons for that many
of my Princeton classmates
and others at Princeton brought pressure
on Shirley Tilghman president Princeton
to resign to create a vacancy and they
wanted Petraeus to become president of
Princeton and then to seek the 2016
Republican nomination as President of
Princeton as Eisenhower had done in 1952
when he was president of Columbia and if
you look at the Republican nominee maybe
that's not question wasn't a bad plan to
begin with but before that could be
affected the whistle was blown on
Petraeus because the Paula Broadwell
affair and and then of course the the
the Princeton Search Committee simply
dismissed him what did you tell General
Petraeus about Kay Summersby and did you
what did he ask you directly on how he
should handle his own problem no no no
we didn't did we discuss we didn't
discuss that we should simply talk about
like in case summers me
well Eisenhower told general Marshall in
1940 just after the VE Day in 1944-45
that he planned to marry Kay Summersby
and divorce me in Mary Kay Summersby and
general Marshall wrote back and said
that's fine if you do but I'll relieve
you of command and so Eisenhower decided
he wouldn't do that but he never took a
and he continued to live with Kay until
he went home to to Washington in
November of 45 when he was reassigned to
become chief of staff of the army and
leaving the command in Europe and he
thought she was going with him and on
the day that she was to park she got
orders ordering her to Berlin where she
was put on the staff general Lucius clay
and she didn't know if she wasn't going
with him and then one sighs now I got
back he wrote her a very crisp Dear John
letter
and that was it Kate continued to pursue
him after her tour in Europe was over
she came back to Washington Selenia in
the Amer
an army and this is a light in the White
House I'm sorry this is Ike in the
Pentagon the next day she received
orders sending her to California so
General Petraeus wasn't very happy when
he saw that story come out about the
footnote was he I don't think so I mean
he was quoted as saying you didn't know
that you were gonna go did was there a
ground rules when you went into that
absolutely not absolutely not but we
were having a friendly dinner if he had
said that I wouldn't work then did you
learn anything from him about the war
and his relationship to the war I didn't
ask you didn't talk about it at all I
didn't I didn't ask I wasn't no I might
say that the military passed him over
for promotion from major instead of
general and he was promoted to
lieutenant general by President Bush on
Rumsfeld recommendation and his career
took a life after that and I think
Petraeus the bush were working together
here's another gentleman that you talked
to Dick Cheney back in the year 2000
talking about the Bush's transition team
let's watch it 40 seconds of this and I
want to ask you about what you learned
from Dick Cheney fact of the matter is
when you put together an administration
one of the things you you look for are
people with experience and we've had a
number of Republican administrations
over the 30-some years that I've been
involved in in national politics and
many of us have had prior experience in
the bush administration but a great many
other administrations as well so the
notion that that somehow that makes us
over rely and you might as well say
we're over relying on the Ford
administration fact is we're looking for
experienced people people who can bring
a lot to the team that the governor Bush
wants to assemble and we welcome folks
regardless of what prior administration
they might have been affiliated with
yes well they're mine but Bush was
governor of Texas and had not been in
Washington and it really didn't know the
Washington scene and he relied on Cheney
Bush picked : Powell to be Secretary of
State
Bush did that he picked Don Rumsfeld to
be Secretary of Defense Bush did that
and he picked his friend to be Secretary
of Commerce a friend from Midland and
otherwise Cheney and ran the search both
for the the cabinet officers and for the
sub cabinet for the sub cabinet officers
and this is unusual it's inconceivable I
think that Franklin Roosevelt would have
asked John Nance Garner to pick his
cabinet and sub cabinet or that
Eisenhower would have asked Nixon to do
that particularly after the Nixon
scandal in the speech this was this was
I think a first in American history
where the president turned over the
selection of most of the people to the
vice president was that a comment on Jan
John Nance Garner
or was that a comment on you know the
ability of Dick Cheney who had served in
the previous administrations and knew a
lot of people no I think it's a comment
on Roosevelt and Bush Roosevelt knew
what he wanted and and knew the
Washington scene don't forget Assistant
Secretary of War for eight years under
Woodrow Wilson he knew the Washington
say any of the politicians in the
Democratic Party and John Nance Garner
was on the ticket to to balance it for
electoral balance not for what he was
going to do and effect it was garner I
think who once said the vice presidency
is not worth a bucket of warm piss with
which is which is right at that time
no I but Bush on the other hand did not
know Washington Cheney did and I think
also Bush knew in Cheney that he wasn't
dealing with the possible political
opponent that given Cheney's age and
given herself he was not going to be a
candidate for president
you interviewed him on May 13th 2013
where I've interviewed Chaney both out
in in Wyoming and Jackson at his house
out in Jackson Hole and a number of
times at his house here in mcclain and I
can't IIIi don't know it by date well
the data isn't as important as how often
did you interview him and what did you
learn from him
well III began by going out to Wyoming
to this is the one that Don set up for
me
and I went out to Wyoming to see him and
Michalis out in Jackson Hole and we we
stayed there for about 207 hours and it
was a very interesting interviewing
Chaney the only ground rule we had was
JD said don't quote me unless you ask me
unless you ask me
I mean don't put anything in quote any
quote marks I mean you can you can use
use the information but don't put it in
quote marks unless unless unless you
tell me and I think the one quote that I
used for the came from that meeting was
where he said which was feeling his way
in foreign policy this was before 9/11
and and I'm not sure that but and out of
his house in Georgetown in McLean
Virginia I might say that Cheney's wife
who was also a writer we got along very
well and that's why I think Cheney was
was quite receptive but as I say Don set
it up for me and so that was fine what
impacted going back you know and when
did you finish writing this
that's I'm not sure I want to answer
that
I finished it about a year ago and and
and Simon & Schuster in their wisdom
held it they they they did not want it
to come out they wanted to come out just
before the Republican convention I think
and so that's why they've held it until
this point so I've been finished it for
about a year she we then suspected Simon
& Schuster did it for political reasons
or for economic reasons well I would say
they did it for economic reasons I think
Simon Schuster though is a democratic
publishing house but but but i think i
think they held it for economic reasons
owned by bob with CBS and whatever i
don't know i don't know that so go back
to when george w bush his office said to
you he's not going to sit and be
interviewed by you what was your
reaction and what impact do you think
that had on the way you felt about the
rest of the book oh it was i was very
close to being finished at that point
and i don't think i don't think it
affected the the book in any way what in
any way that was okay I could understand
that he would take that position and it
I don't it had no effect on the one the
manuscript there's AB you quote from a
fellow named Russ Baker who has been a
journalist for never years he wrote a
book called family of secrets mm-hmm
george w bush's record at Harvard was
uninspiring quote he had 53 job
interviews with Fortune 500 companies
unquote said fellow Harvard Business
School graduate bill white but no job
offer
I assume that's the bill white of
Houston the former mayor of Houston I
don't know quote he is the only Harvard
Business School I know that let me read
it he's the only Harvard Business School
graduate that I know of who left there
without a GED job I don't think sigh
it's a
that's made of bushes but I don't think
he was that's the same guy no but I'm
really more interested in that why that
quote how that quote defined George Bush
and European because that's a that's on
page 27 yeah well that's when he went
back to Harvard to Harvard Business
School well I think let me quote one of
his classmates told me that they
considered him dynamically ignorant that
he was it was very active very energetic
but-but-but-but didn't know anything
anything good about him well he was very
energetic but besides that and your book
I know you say positive things about oh
yes the way he held the financial crisis
what about the financial crisis I think
his leadership on combating aids
internationally was its no president has
done that which which he did he led the
fight against AIDS and I think turned
the corner on AIDS in Africa and I think
he deserves great credit for that I'm 83
he had in Medicare two had two Medicare
prescription drugs for seniors and I
think No Child Left Behind is a valuable
addition I think he got along well with
Putin initially and I think the fact
that he and Putin agreed to reduce the
number of nuclear weapons they each
country maintains is a remarkable
achievement I also think he improved
relations with China a lot of people
didn't want him to go to the Peking
Olympics and he did and I think I think
that that helped improve relations with
China and free trade when Bush became
president the United States had
free-trade agreements with Israel Canada
and Mexico when he left we had free
trade agreements with 16 countries so I
think it's not an administration without
without some success and I think that's
why I explicitly stayed in the book that
he's not America's worst president it's
pretty hard for anyone to beat Herbert
Hoover but but
I that doesn't detract from the fact
that his decision to attack Iraq may be
the worst foreign policy decision the
president ever made
and when I asked you about that because
the first sentence in your book and the
last sentence in your book are I want to
know frankly if you decided to do this
on purpose and at what point let me read
the first sentence of your entire book
in the preface rarely in the history of
the United States has the nation been so
ill served as during the presidency of
George W Bush how long did it take you
to get to that sentence to start your
book that's probably the first sentence
I wrote as I said III do a book from
front to back
chronologically and I do the preface
first and I did the preface before I
started writing the book so I put that
sense in the preface and then I read the
conclusion without checking it and and I
didn't know that they were so similar
until I read their book reviews really
no I I didn't I didn't look at let me
read the last sentence then of the
entire book on page 660 whether George W
Bush was the worst president American
history will be long debated but his
decision to invade Iraq is easily the
worst foreign policy decision ever made
by an American president how did you get
to that point
well you look if you're a historian you
know what other presidents have done and
I can't think of a decision that was any
worse maybe you could say Harry Truman's
decision to drop the atomic bomb on
Hiroshima and Nagasaki maybe that was a
worse decision maybe but that's about
that's about the only contender what
about Woodrow Wilson's decision to go
into World War one well the Germans it
helped that a great deal when they sunk
sunk American ships at sea and Wilson
acted in responsive this is the Germans
the military aggression
what about JFK and LBJ decision to go
into the Vietnam situation 58,000 lives
later and some people think it's had a
dramatic impact over the last 50 years
on us oh I don't think so I'd fit 58,000
lives were 58,000 lives and there's been
no terrorist
there was no terrorist activity after
after the Vietnam War it was it was the
local it was a local war so how much
responsibility and you put on george w
bush for the terrorist activity in the
world today well I would say 100% I
would say that if he had left Saddam
Hussein in control of Iraq he would not
have the which was a secular state at
the time it wasn't a democracy but it
was a secular state and he kept a lid on
on Isis extremism there was no Isis al
Qaeda wasn't even in Iraq and so I would
say that was a removal of song Hussein
that is behind the terrorists that we
have today let me go to the
acknowledgments in the back because I
want to ask you about a fella by the
name of Sanford a lake off yes you say
John a 1954 classmate of mine at
Princeton read the manuscript for every
chapter of every book I have written
beginning with the defense of Berlin in
1963 but he has died since then he's
died I think he died in nineteen twenty
thirteen I think it's what you say in
the book them so why did he read every
chapter of every book that you've ever
written well we were roommates at
Princeton and and we were good friends
and so he he just agreed to do it gang
of thirteen yes the gang of thirteen who
are they what I mean not by name but it
was whenever I finished I do it chapter
by chapter as I said and whenever I
finish the chapter I send it out to
these thirteen people and they read it
and they they send me their comments on
the chapter and I don't go back to them
I mean that they send the chapter to me
and it's a one-shot deal and I
but their their comments were and if I
like it I use it if I don't I don't who
are these folks and what kind of friends
are they well they're people I've met
over the years to take Ellen film and
Ellen Feldman I met after she wrote a
book about Franklin and Lucy Rutherford
and she's a novelist she reads them John
I mentioned my roommate at Prince and
Harry Mel I mentioned did you send a
copy of your book before you published
it to Don ROM so III think don know who
you what I was writing did he try to
change your mind oh sure oh sure if you
feel I was wrong on something he's ever
told me I was wrong on something did he
what did you gather work the personal
opinion from Don Rumsfeld and Dick
Cheney about George Bush I never pressed
them on their personal views about
George Bush I I thought that would be
pushing the envelope a bit and and so I
never pressed them about their their
personal views on Bush I think it like
in any politician I think that they had
skepticism when I show you some video of
a fella that you talk about and I think
you knew his father this is only about
20 seconds this was back in October the
18th 2002 and his name is Paul Wolfowitz
Saddam Hussein supports and conspires
with our terrorist enemies he lends them
both moral and material support
disarming Saddam Hussein and fighting
the war on terror are not merely related
they are part of the same struggle and
if we can defeat a terrorist regime in
Iraq it will be a defeat for terrorists
globally what impact did he have on
the Iraq war he encouraged but I don't I
don't think it was crucial he was on the
same on the same side as Bush and but
but but but I don't think I I don't
think he spawned it IIIi think he was
perfectly happy to go along with it and
did you know his father I'm sorry did
you know his father III I did not know
well
back when in the 1960s when the camp get
a great deal of campus unrest rides at
Columbia and Berkeley and and Cornell
feel Horton the editor the reporter
magazine asked me if I would go up to
Cornell and interview this particular
professor of mathematics who had
interesting insight into the nature of
the student protests and so I did and
then professor it was professor
Wolfowitz in the mathematics department
and professor Wolfowitz told me that
that he was convinced that this was a
communist plot and the prelude to a
communist revolution and whenever I
wrote the article and Horton thought it
was a little bit too far out and so they
didn't the reporter didn't use it so are
you going to write another book I'm 83
years old and it's difficult it's
difficult to write because it have
things changed as you've gotten older I
think more slowly and I write more
slowly and it takes longer and I I mean
at 83 I'm not sure that I have another
four or five years and which I could
write a biography but I think Simon
Chester wants me to to do something else
and I thought I would write about the
decision to save Paris in World War two
and I think that the German General von
colt it's an Eisenhower deserve great
credit for saving Paris from destruction
in World War two I don't think many
people are aware of it but eisenhower
lived for a year and a half in Paris in
the 1920s and living in Paris in the
1920s as he did when he was on Pershing
staff in Paris he knew Paris and I think
Vaughn Colton's deserves great credit
for refusing to carry out this order so
I think there's an artbook there but I'm
not sure and he started it you outlined
it
no I I've read I have read the
background material and I've read the
background material 32 years at the
University of Toronto 33 but yes yeah I
thought my ears at Marshall 12 and are
you consider yourself retired well yeah
I'm not in the classroom anymore after
Marshall I went to Columbia for two
years as a senior scholar and then to
Georgetown for two years as a visiting
scholar and I yeah I guess that was a
Dartmouth for two years before I went to
Toronto our guest has been Jean Edward
Smith the book is called bush